quand on pense au spatial on pense
souvent aux astronautes mais la filière
regorge de différents métiers à l'école
d'ingénieurs l'estaca situé en partie à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines professeurs et
étudiants tentent de faire connaître la
filière au plus grand nombre
c'est une filière qui était censé donc
se développer à partir de la filière
aéronautique donc qui concernaient un
nombre limité d'étudiants de plus en
plus d'étudiants veulent y travailler
d'une part parce que ça passionne
beaucoup de monde
et puis deuxièmement il ya quand même de
plus en plus de donc de demandes et de
besoins dans également dans l'industrie
dans cette formation ni rentrer avec
déjà un bac + 3 qui peut s'effectuer au
sein de l'école d'ingénieur puis deux
ans pour comprendre et apprendre ce qui
se trame dans l'organisation d'une
mission spatiale mais aussi sur tous
ceux qui y contribuent à son autre c
j'ai fait j'aime bien cette image les
déjà repayée sel c'est la partie
immergée de l'iceberg c'est à dire qu'il
ya c'est ce qu'on voit en premier par
contre il ya beaucoup de travail de fond
derrière pour arriver à faire une
mission spatiale et qui fait travailler
énormément de deux personnes des
scientifiques des ingénieurs parmi les
étudiants de la filière spatiale de
l'estaca manon bordeaux en quatrième
année
son rêve travailler sur la propulsion
des fusées son ambition devenir
ingénieur d'essai moteur au sein d'un
grand groupe spatiale trouve ça
merveilleux de pouvoir travailler dans
ce domaine là et de lancer des hommes
des femmes qui pourront accomplir leur
rêve d'aller dans l'espace et enfin déjà
rien que voir sa fusée décoller c'est un
accomplissement de tout le projet de
tout le travail qu'on a fait dessus donc
c'est déjà magnifique à l'estaca plus de
2000 étudiants sont formés chaque année
aux différents métiers de l'ingénierie
pour manon bordeaux comme pour didier
gignac l'avenir de la filière spatiale
est assurée la conquête spatiale ne fait
que commencer